>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
HERE'S A HAPPY MEMORY.
BY BREAKFAST, REALLY EVEN BRUNCH
ON ELECTION DAY, 2016, VIRTUALLY
NOBODY IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
THOUGHT DONALD TRUMP AND WIN.
AND THEY DIDN'T THINK THAT
BECAUSE THE ENTIRE PRESS CORPS
HAD BEEN TELLING THEM FOR MONTHS
THAT TRUMP HAD, AS THEY ARE WAS
PUT IT, LITERALLY NO CHANCE, NOT
EVEN AS AN ABSTRACT, THEORETICAL
MATTER.
THIS WASN'T ACTUALLY A RACE.
COME NOVEMBER 8TH, YOU'LL
REMEMBER THIS, DONALD TRUMP IS
GOING TO BE DROWNED BY OF
TOWERING BLUE SYNONYMY AND SWEPT
AWAY FOREVER ALONG WITH THE REST
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, THE
COLLABORATORS ANYWAY.
POLLING NUMBERS SEEMED TO
CONFIRM THAT THIS WAS BACK TO
HAPPEN AND SO, BY THE WAY, TO
THE PRIVATE BETTING MARKETS.
AT LEAST ONE OF THOSE MARKETS
HAD SET THE SPREAD IT 80/20 FOR
HILLARY CLINTON.
IN THE END THEY WERE NOT ONLY
WRONG, THEY WERE HILARIOUSLY
WRONG, BY MIDNIGHT HE HAD WON
AND A LOT OF HIGHLY EDUCATED,
EXTREMELY WELL CREDENTIALED
PEOPLE LOOKED AT RIDICULES.
HILLARY CLINTON HERSELF WAS SO
SHOCKED BY THE RESULT THAT NIGHT
THAT SHE REFUSED TO GIVE A
CONCESSION SPEECH.
SHE WENT TO BED HOPING IT WAS
JUST A DREAM.
YOU PROBABLY REMEMBER ALL OF
THAT VERY WELL.
BUT IT WAS WHAT HAPPENED NEXT IN
THE DAYS BETWEEN THE ELECTION
AND THANKSGIVING THAT IT TURNS
OUT IN A LOT OF WAYS WAS MUCH
MORE IMPORTANT.
WHAT HAPPENED DURING THAT PERIOD
SET THE COURSE FOR WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW, AND WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW IS SPEEDING TOWARDS
ONE OF THE GREAT DISASTERS IN
OUR HISTORY.
THE LEADERS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY COULDN'T, IN EFFECT,
HANDLE THE OUTCOME OF THE 2016
ELECTION.
THEY SNAPPED UNDER THE STRAIN OF
IT, UNDER THE CRUSHED
EXPECTATIONS.
BUT RATHER THAN LOOK INWARD AND
ASSESS THEIR OWN ROLE IN THE
DISASTER, WHAT DID WE DO WRONG?
WHITED VOTERS REJECT US, AND
OTHER QUESTIONS THAT EMOTIONALLY
MATURE MATURE ADULTS MIGHT'VE
ASKED.
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS INSTEAD SET
OUT TO BLAME SOME DEALS FOR THE
RESULTS AND SOON THEY SETTLED ON
RUSSIA.
VLADIMIR PUTIN GOT DONALD TRUMP
ELECTED, THEY TOLD US.
HILLARY CLINTON SAID THAT
REPEATEDLY.
NOW, AT FIRST IT WAS HARD TO
TAKE ANY OF IT VERY SERIOUSLY.
WE TRIED, BUT THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE IT WAS TRUE AT ALL.
AND SO A RATIONAL PERSON CAN GO
TO THE OBVIOUS.
THIS WAS A CHILDISH LIKE A
LOGICAL DEFENSE MECHANISM, NOT A
FACTUAL CLAIM.
AND YET THEY KEPT SAYING IT.
IN THE FACE OF NO EVIDENCE.
AND OVER TIME THEY BEGAN ACTING
ON IT LIKE IT WAS TRUE AND EVEN
OVER MORE TIME THEY PARALYZED
THE ENTIRE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FOR YEARS, FRUITLESSLY TRYING TO
PROVE THE CORE CLAIMS OF
RUSSIAGATE BUT THEY COULDN'T
BECAUSE THOSE TWO COINS WEREN'T
TRUE AND GET CRITICALLY THEY
CLUNG TO THOSE CLAIMS.
THEY NEVER STOP REPEATING THE
TALKING POINTS.
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT "HACKED"
OUR ELECTION.
THAT WAS JEN PSAKI NOT LONG AGO
SAYING IT OUT LOUD LIKE IT WERE
TRUE.
HERE'S THE CONTEXT.
AS SHE SAID THAT, SHE WAS TRYING
TO EXPLAIN WHY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS IN EFFECT
WORKING TO OVERTHROW THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOW.
AND FOR ONCE, SHE WAS TELLING
THE TRUTH, THAT IS WHY.
DEMOCRATS HAVE CONVINCED
THEMSELVES THAT RUSSIA STOLE THE
PRESIDENCY WHICH RIGHTFULLY
BELONGED TO HILLARY CLINTON, AND
THEY MEAN IT WHEN THEY SAID, AND
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE TAKING US TO
WAR WITH RUSSIA.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS GOING
ON HERE, A LOT OF THREADS, AS IN
ANY BIG STORY, BUT ON SOME
LEVEL, THE CORE MOTIVATION IS
JUST THAT SIMPLE.
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW IT'S NOT.
WE KNOW THE WAR IN UKRAINE IS
NOT ABOUT SAVING DEMOCRACY.
PLEASE.
WE KNOW IT'S NOT ABOUT
PROTECTING THE SACRED BORDERS OF
A SOVEREIGN COUNTRY.
WE KNOW THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THOSE
PRINCIPLES BECAUSE THEY RUN OUR
COUNTRY AND WE SEE HOW THEY ACT.
AND WHEN OFFERED AT CERTAIN --
AND THIS COMES AS SAD NEWS TO A
LOT OF AMERICANS WERE
COMPASSIONATE -- BUT WE KNOW NOW
THAT THE WAR IS NOT ABOUT
HELPING THE UKRAINE PEOPLE,
THOSE POOR PEOPLE.
MANY MORE UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS
WILL DIE, CERTAINLY, THANKS TO
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S
POLICIES.
IF YOU WANT TO SAVE UKRAINE, ITS
PEOPLE, ITS INFRASTRUCTURE, ITS
NATION, YOU WOULD PUSH FOR A
SETTLEMENT NOW.
YOU WOULD HAVE DONE IT TWO
MONTHS AGO, BUT THEY ARE NOT
DOING THAT.
THAT'S NOT THEIR GOAL, SAVING
UKRAINE, SAVING HUMAN LIVES.
NO, THAT'S NOT THEIR GOAL.
INSTEAD, THE WAR IN UKRAINE IS
DESIGNED TO CAUSE REGIME CHANGE
IN MOSCOW.
THEY WANT TO TOPPLE THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
THAT WOULD BE PAYBACK FOR THE
2016 ELECTION.
SO THIS IS THE LOGICAL, MAY BE
THE INEVITABLE END STAGE OF
RUSSIA-GATE.
OF WE SHOULD HAVE SEEN IT COMING
BECAUSE THEY SAID IT OUT LOUD.
YEARS AGO.
HERE'S ADAM SCHIFF FROM TWO
YEARS AGO PREDICTING IT, SAYING
IT.
WATCH THIS.
>> IS ONE WITNESS PUT IT DURING
OUR IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY, THE
UNITED STATES AIDS UKRAINE AND
HER PEOPLE SO THAT WE CAN FIGHT
RUSSIA OVER THERE AND WE DON'T
HAVE TO FIGHT RUSSIA HERE.
>> Tucker: SO WE ARM UKRAINE
SO WE CAN FIGHT RUSSIA.
HOW MANY AMERICANS, WHATEVER YOU
THINK OF PUTIN -- PROBABLY NOT
MUCH, JUSTIFIABLY -- PROBABLY
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF INTEREST IN
MOVING TO RUSSIA, BUT HOW MANY
AMERICANS THEN OR NOW WANT TO
"FIGHT RUSSIA"?
A VERY SMALL GROUP.
BUT ADAM SCHIFF SAID IT OUT LOUD
AT THE TIME IN THE HOUSE OF A
PERCENTAGE.
WE DON'T ARM UKRAINE SO WE CAN
HELP UKRAINIANS, THEY ARE MERELY
UNFORTUNATE PONDS AND ALL OF
THIS.
WE ARM UKRAINE SO THAT WE CAN
PUNISH RUSSIA.
WHY?
FOR STEALING HILLARY CLINTON'S
CORONATION.
IF ONLY WE HAD TAKEN ADAM SCHIFF
SERIOUSLY AS HE SAID IT AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN, BUT NOW WE
CAN'T HELP BUT TAKE ADAM SCHIFF
SERIOUSLY BECAUSE HE'S ONE OF
THE PRIME MOVERS OF THIS WAR.
ADAM SCHIFF SPENT THIS WEEKEND
IN EASTERN EUROPE CHECKING ON
THE PROGRESS OF THE WAR HE HAS
DONE SO MUCH TO BRING ABOUT.
HE TRAVELED THERE WITH
NANCY PELOSI AND A NUMBER OF
OTHER OF THE MOST
CONSPIRACY-MINDED DEMOCRATS IN
CONGRESS.
THESE ARE THE RUSSIAGATE TRUE
BELIEVERS SEEING THEIR THEORY
COME TO FRUITION.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS.
HERE'S THE GROUP PELOSI,
ADAM SCHIFF, AND THE REST,
MEETING WITH THE PRESIDENT IN
UKRAINE.
>> NICE TO MEET YOU, THANK YOU
FOR COMING.
>> GOVERNOR OF MASSACHUSETTS.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> [INDISCERNIBLE].
>> ADAM SCHIFF, CALIFORNIA.
HONORED TO MEET YOU.
>> Tucker: SO HOW DID
ADAM SCHIFF AND NANCY PELOSI
WIND UP IN CHARGE OF AMERICA'S
FOREIGN POLICY AS WE STAND ON
THE CUSP OF A THIRD WORLD WAR?
AND WHY ARE REPUBLICANS
SUPPORTING THEM, AND WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU PUT PEOPLE WITH
A DEMONSTRATED LACK OF
BOUNDARIES OR SELF-CONTROL OR
WISDOM IN CHARGE OF SOMETHING AS
IMPORTANT AS THE FATE OF
NATIONS?
WELL, HERE'S WHAT HAPPENS.
WATCH AS ONE AFTER THE OTHER
DEMOCRATS YOU JUST SAW ON TAPE
ANNOUNCED THAT THIS REGIME
CHANGE IS NOT NEARLY OVER, IN
FACT THIS WAR HAS JUST BEGUN.
WATCH.
>> ONE THING IS REALLY CLEAR,
THAT THIS DELEGATION WANTED
TO -- BE VERY CLEAR WITH HIS
MOST RECENT AID PACKAGE REQUEST.
IT IS A HISTORIC REQUEST THAT WE
ARE GOING TO PUSH HARD IN THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS TO HELP
PASS AND IT SENDS A VERY SIMPLE
MESSAGE.
WE ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
STALEMATES.
WE ARE NOT INTERESTED IN GOING
BACK TO THE STATUS QUO.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA IS
IN THIS TO WIN IT AND WE WILL
STAND WITH UKRAINE UNTIL VICTORY
IS WON.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS CONGRESS
WHEN JASON CROW, A CONFIRMED
BUFFOON, TELLING US THAT WE ARE
NOT IN IT TO ACHIEVE A
STALEMATE.
WE?
REALLY?
SOME OF US WERE UNDER THE
IMPRESSION BASED ON THEIR'S
PUBLIC STATEMENTS THAT WE WERE
DEFENDING THE SOVEREIGNTY OF
ANOTHER COUNTRY, UKRAINE.
BUT IT'S NOT UP TO US, IT'S UP
TO THE VOTERS IN UKRAINE,
BECAUSE UKRAINE IS A DEMOCRACY.
HERE IS THE CONGRESSMAN TELLING
US WE ARE NOT GOING TO ACCEPT A
"STALEMATE."
WE ARE IN IT TO WIN IT.
WE'RE GOING TO WIN, WE ARE HERE
UNTIL WE GET VICTORY.
THAT RAISES THE OBVIOUS
QUESTION, WHAT IS WINNING?
WHAT IS VICTORY?
HOW DO WE KNOW WHEN WE WON?
HE DIDN'T TELL US.
AND NEITHER, BY THE WAY, DID
NANCY PELOSI.
SHE JUST THAT WE ARE GOING TO
KEEP SENDING WEAPONS TO UKRAINE
"UNTIL THE FIGHT IS DONE."
>> TO SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FIGHT OF FREEDOM, AND THAT YOUR
FIGHT IS A FIGHT FOR EVERYONE.
AND SO OUR COMMITMENT IS TO BE
THERE FOR YOU UNTIL THE FIGHT IS
DONE.
>> Tucker: HOW DID WE GET HERE
EXACTLY?
YOU FEEL BETRAYED?
IF YOU'RE ONE OF THE MILLIONS OF
GOOD-HEARTED AMERICANS WHO PUT A
UKRAINIAN FLAG PIN ON YOUR LAPEL
OR PUT ONE IN FRONT OF HER HOUSE
EXPRESSING SOLIDARITY WITH THE
POOR, OPPRESSED PEOPLE OF
UKRAINE, YOU PROBABLY DIDN'T
THINK YOU ARE SIGNING UP FOR
THIS.
NANCY PELOSI TELLING US WE ARE
IN A WAR WITH A NUCLEAR ARMED
POWER WITH NO CLEAR END GAME.
SEEN THAT MOVIE BEFORE?
WE JUST FINISHED ONE AFTER 20
YEARS IN AFGHANISTAN.
WILL IT LOOK LIKE THAT?
THIS IS AN OPEN-ENDED CONFLICT,
SAID NANCY PELOSI, JUST LIKE THE
WAR ON TERROR, AND JUST IN CASE
YOU MISSED IT, THEY ALL REPEATED
THAT LINE.
HERE'S HER NIGHTMARE AGAIN,
ADAM SCHIFF IN CHARGE OF THE WAR
AGAINST RUSSIA.
WATCH.
>> THE WHOLE FREEDOM LOVING
WORLD HAS AN INTEREST IN THE
OUTCOME OF THIS WAR AND ENSURING
THAT UKRAINE IS VICTORIOUS, AND
WE ARE DETERMINED TO DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO MAKE
IT SO.
WE ARE PROUD TO STAND SHOULDER
TO SHOULDER WITH UKRAINE, AND WE
WILL.
>> Tucker: THESE PEOPLE ARE
PLAYING DRESS-UP.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT, AND THEY DON'T
CARE.
THEY GET TO PRETEND TO BE
STATESMAN FOR A DAY.
BUT WHEN ADAM SCHIFF AND
NANCY PELOSI -- AGAIN, PEOPLE
WITH A DEMONSTRATED, YEARS LONG
RECORD OF BEING WILLING TO SAY
ANYTHING FOR PERSONAL POWER,
ANYTHING TO IMPROVE THE FORTUNES
OF THE LOCAL PARTY -- WHEN THEY
ARE STANDING UP WITH A FOREIGN
HEAD OF STATE SAYING THERE'S AN
OPEN CHECK, YOU FILL IN THE
NUMBER, YOU'VE GOT TO WONDER
WHERE THIS IS GOING.
WE KNOW WHERE IT COULD GO.
THIS IS THE MOST RECKLESS
FOREIGN POLICY IN OUR LIFETIMES,
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
YOU ARE WATCHING A GROUP OF
DECADENT AND SOME CASES SENILE
LEADERS CASUALLY DISMISS THE
CONSEQUENCES OF GOING TO WAR
WITH A NUCLEAR ARMED NATION.
DISMISS THE CONSEQUENCES OF
NUCLEAR WAR LIKE IT'S NOT EVEN
WORTH THINKING ABOUT.
BUT IT IS WORTH THINKING ABOUT.
THEY TELL US DAILY
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS EVIL AND
INSANE, AND THAT MAY WELL BE
TRUE, BUT THIS SAME MAN HAS
THREATENED TO USE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES AND WESTERN EUROPE
IF THIS CONTINUES, AND WHY DON'T
WE BELIEVE HIM?
YOU MAY HAVE MISSED THIS,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" DIDN'T SEEM
TO HAVE TIME TO COVER IT.
BUT HERE'S RUSSIA'S FOREIGN
MINISTER JUST LAST WEEK
UNDERSCORING THE POINT.
>> RUSSIAN FOREIGN MINISTER WITH
A CHILLING WARNING, THE RISK OF
NUCLEAR WAR IS A REAL ONE.
SPEAKING TO STATE RUN MEDIA, HE
SAID "THE DANGER WAS SERIOUS,
ISRAEL, IT CANNOT BE UNDER
ESTIMATED."
HE ADDED THAT HE DID NOT WANT TO
SEE THE RISK TO NUCLEAR WAR
"ARTIFICIALLY INFLATED."
>> Tucker: HE DOES NOT SEE IT
AS AN ARTIFICIALLY INFLATED.
SO WHAT THEY ARE SAYING IS WE
WILL USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS AGAINST
YOU AND YOUR ALLIES IF YOU DON'T
BACK OFF.
IF, FOR EXAMPLE, THIS SEEMS
EXISTENTIAL, LIKE YOU'RE TRYING
TRYING TO OVERTHROW OUR
GOVERNMENT.
IT'S HARDLY IN DEFENSE OF RUSSIA
TO SAY THAT'S A POSSIBILITY, AND
HAS BEEN FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
SO IT WAS TWO YEARS AGO THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN REVISED RUSSIA'S
NUCLEAR DETERRENT POLICY.
THE NEW POLICY ALLOWS RUSSIA TO
USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS IN RESPONSE
TO A CONVENTIONAL STRIKE.
THAT MEANS SOME SORT OF
NONNUCLEAR PROVOCATION.
IN MARCH, RUSSIA'S FORMER
PRESIDENT DMITRY MEDVEDEV, WHO
SITS ON RUSSIA'S SECURITY
COUNCIL, REMINDED OUR COUNTRY OF
THIS POLICY.
HE WARNED JOE BIDEN THAT RUSSIA
WOULD INDEED USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS
AGAINST THE WEST IN RESPONSE TO
ANY "ACT OF AGGRESSION" THAT IS
COMMITTED AGAINST RUSSIA AND ITS
ALLIES.
WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE?
WOULD INCLUDE HELPING TO SHOOT
DOWN A RUSSIAN TRANSPORT PLANE
CARRYING HUNDREDS OF RUSSIAN
TROOPS?
THE PENTAGON HAS ADMITTED DOING
THAT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE FOR RUSSIA
TO SEE THAT AS A PRETTY RECKLESS
ACT AND NOT JUST DOING IT BUT
THEN BRAGGING ABOUT IT TO
NBC NEWS.
WHERE DOES THAT GET US?
WE SHOULD FIND OUT.
WE DO KNOW THAT PUTIN HAS PLACED
RUSSIA'S NUCLEAR FORCES ON HIGH
ALERT, AND AGAIN, RUSSIA HAS THE
LARGEST NUCLEAR ARSENAL IN THE
WORLD, AND AGAIN, WHY WOULDN'T
HE USE THOSE WEAPONS?
THEY TELL US DAILY HE IS EVIL
AND INSANE AND HE MAY WELL BE.
A RISK?
YEAH.
BUT NO ONE IN WASHINGTON SEEMS
WORRIED IN THE SLIGHTEST.
IN FACT, CONGRESSMAN
ADAM KINZINGER, WITH CLEARLY
SOMETHING TO LOOK FOR AT THIS
POINT, IS NOT GOING TO A BLANK
CHECK I'M AN OPEN-ENDED CONFLICT
IN UKRAINE USING THE SAME LEGAL
JUSTIFICATION THAT GOT US INTO
IRAQ FOR NEARLY 20 YEARS.
HE WANTS AN AUTHORIZATION TO USE
MILITARY FORCE.
WATCH.
>> SENATOR KAINE WAS WITH US AND
HE SAID IT IS TOO SOON TO BEGIN
TALKING ABOUT POTENTIAL USE OF
FORCE IN UKRAINE.
DO YOU THINK IS RIGHT?
>> NO.
I DON'T.
I DON'T THINK WE NEED TO BE
USING FORCE IN UKRAINE RIGHT
NOW.
I JUST INTRODUCED AN
AUTHORIZATION FOR THE USE OF
MILITARY FORCE GIVING THE
PRESIDENT BASICALLY
CONGRESSIONAL LEVERAGE OR
PERMISSION TO USE IT IF WMDs,
NUCLEAR BIOLOGICAL OR CHEMICAL
OR USE IN UKRAINE.
DOES IT COMPEL THE PRESIDENT TO
DO IT?
IT JUST SAYS IF IT IS USED HE
HAS THAT LEVERAGE.
THEY MAY BE A POINT WHERE WE
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE, LOOK, THIS
IS -- PRIOR TO WORLD WAR II
THERE WERE MOMENTS NOBODY EVER
WANTED TO GET INVOLVED AND
EVENTUALLY CAME TO REALIZE THEY
HAD TO.
I HOPE WE DON'T GET TO THAT
POINT HERE, BUT WE SHOULD BE
READY IF WE DO.
>> Tucker: PRIOR TO
WORLD WAR II, SAYS
ADAM KINZINGER.
SO LAST YEAR, ADAM KINZINGER WAS
A GUY WHO HAD BEEN REDISTRICTED
OUT OF HIS OWN DISTRICT AND WAS
TROLLING FOR SOME KIND OF CABLE
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR-SHIP.
FUTURE LOOKED GRIM FOR
ADAM KINZINGER.
NOW ADAM KINZINGER IS ON THE
SUNDAY SHOWS EVERY WEEK AND
DOING HIS WINSTON CHURCHILL
LIMITATION.
YOU CAN SEE THE BUILT-IN
INCENTIVE FOR MEDIOCRE AND
INTELLECTUALLY LIMITED NUMBERS
OF CONGRESS TO PLAY THE WAR
HAWK.
BUT YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF,
WHY ALL OF A SUDDEN IS EVERYBODY
TALKING ABOUT CHEMICAL AND
BIOLOGICAL WEAPONS?
JUST A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
JOE BIDEN, THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES, PROMISED TO
RESPOND "IN-KIND" TO POTENTIAL
USE OF CHEMICAL WEAPONS BY
RUSSIA.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE
UNITED STATES WOULD USE ITS
CHEMICAL WEAPONS AGAINST THE
RUSSIANS IF THEY USED THERE IS
AGAINST UKRAINE, AND THEN,
BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO
ADMIT THAT YOU HAVE CHEMICAL
WEAPONS, THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR FOR JOE BIDEN, WHOSE
MEMORY STILL WORKS, WALKED BACK
AND SAID THE PRESIDENT MISSPOKE
JUST LIKE HE DID WHEN HE TOLD US
THIS WAS A REGIME CHANGE WAR.
WE WOULD NEVER USE CHEMICAL
WEAPONS.
BUT FOR SOME REASON, A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON IN BOTH
PARTIES ARE STILL TALKING A LOT
ABOUT THE U.S. USING CHEMICAL
WEAPONS IN RUSSIA.
HERE'S ONE OF THE MOST LIMITED
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
MICHAEL McCAUL, REPUBLICAN
FROM TEXAS, WIDELY REGARDED AS A
HEALTH PIECE FOR THE INTEL
AGENCIES, LISTEN TO WHAT HE
SAYS.
>> WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF A
CHEMICAL WEAPON WAS DROPPED IN
UKRAINE AND/OR A SHORT RANGE
TACTICAL NUKE?
THE QUESTION THERE IS WHAT THE
WORLD IDOL HE SIT BACK AND WATCH
THAT HAPPEN WITHOUT DOING
ANYTHING?
>> IT WILL BE WHAT SHOULD WE DO.
>> I JUST FIND IT HARD TO
BELIEVE, AND WHEN I TALKED TO
THE SECRETARY GENERAL OF NATO,
THEIR JOB IS REALLY TO DEFEND
NATO, NOT TRIGGER ARTICLE FIVE,
BUT IN MY JUDGMENT, THAT'S
BEYOND THE PALE.
THAT CROSSES A REDLINE, AND I
THINK IF THAT HAPPENS, WE WOULD
HAVE TO RESPOND IN KIND.
>> Tucker: SO STORIES LIKE
THIS GIVE PEOPLE LIKE HIM A
CHANCE TO GIVE YOU A MORAL
LECTURE ON TELEVISION, WHICH IS
THE WHOLE APPEAL, BUT AGAIN, ALL
OF A SUDDEN YOU HAVE SITTING
NUMBERS OF CONGRESS WITH ACCESS
TO HIGH-LEVEL INTELLIGENCE
TALKING CASUALLY ABOUT USING
CHEMICAL WEAPONS OR NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AGAINST A NUCLEAR ARMED
STATE.
SO IT'S NOT A DEFENSE OF RUSSIA,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BELIEVE RUSSIA
WAS JUSTIFIED IN INVADING
UKRAINE -- THEY WEREN'T.
IT'S NOT A DEFENSE OF PUTIN TO
THINK TO YOURSELF "HOLD ON A
SECOND TIER, HOW DID WE GET HERE
TALKING ABOUT NUCLEAR WAR IN THE
SUNDAY SHOWS?
SHOULD WE BE?
ARE WE READY FOR THAT?
WAS GOAT IT'S CLEAR NO ONE IN
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CARE OR
IS WORRIED ABOUT
IT AT ALL.
THE ESCALATION CONTINUES AT A
REMARKABLE PACE, AND YOU KNOW
THAT IF YOU WATCH THE MONEY.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO SHOVEL CASH
TO THE GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE,
WHICH JUST LAST YEAR DEMOCRATS
DESCRIBED AS ONE OF THE MOST
CORRUPT IN THE WORLD, BUT
WHATEVER.
AND WE ARE SENDING MONEY TO
UKRAINE AT LEVELS THAT ARE
ASTOUNDING.
JOE BIDEN SIGNED OFF ON THE
FUNDING PACKAGE IN MARCH FOR
$13.6 BILLION IN AID FOR
UKRAINE.
THEN HE SENT AN ADDITIONAL
1.3 BILLION IN APRIL.
THEN HE SENT 350 MILLION IN
FEBRUARY.
HE ALSO SENT 800 MILLION IN
MARCH.
IN ADDITION TO ALL OF THAT HE
HAS REQUESTED ANOTHER
$33 BILLION FOR UKRAINE, AND
THAT REQUEST INCLUDES FUNDING
FOR "LONGER-RANGE ARTILLERY OF A
HEAVIER CALIBER."
IN OTHER WORDS, WE ARE SENDING
ARTILLERY TO UKRAINE THAT COULD
EASILY STRIKE RUSSIAN TERRITORY
WE ARE SENDING $33 BILLION TO DO
IT.
HOW MUCH IS 33 BILLION?
IN A MOMENT WHEN CONGRESS IS
WRITING CHECKS FOR TRILLIONS.
TO PUT INTO CONTEXT, $33 BILLION
IS MORE THAN DOUBLE WHAT THE BY
DEMONSTRATION SPENDS PROTECTING
OUR NATIONAL BORDERS, AND THAT'S
JUST ONE CHECK TO UKRAINE.
BUT IT'S DOUBLE THE ANNUAL
BUDGET TO PROTECT OUR BORDERS.
THE BY DEMONSTRATION JUST
REQUESTED 15 BILLION FOR THE
ENTIRE BUDGET FOR U.S. CUSTOMS
AND BORDER PROTECTION.
AND JUST 8 BILLION FOR THE U.S.
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT.
SO WE ARE SPENDING TWICE ON
THEIR BORDERS WHAT WE SPEND ON
OUR OWN AND ONE REQUEST, IN ONE
WEEK.
HOW MUCH IS 33 BILLION?
WHILE, IT'S MORE THAN WE SPEND
ON VETERANS AFFAIRS EVERY MONTH.
TAKING CARE OF OUR OWN VETERANS.
AND THE SADDEST POINT OF ALL OF
THIS IS IT HASN'T CAUSED THE
RUSSIANS TO WITHDRAW FROM
UKRAINE, AND NO ONE IS CLAIMING
THAT IT WILL.
IT HASN'T BANKRUPTED PUTIN, IT
HASN'T CRIPPLED THE RUSSIAN
ECONOMY, IT CERTAINLY RUINED OUR
ECONOMY.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
THE DAILY MAIL IS REPORTING THAT
A RUSSIAN OLIGARCH WITH CLOSE TO
TIES TO BOTTOM RECRUIT AND SHE'S
ON THE BAD GUY LIST, RIGHT?
NO.
BECAUSE HE MET WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S SON IN MOSCOW DEVIL
TIMES TO DISCUSS INVESTMENT
DEALS.
SO THAT OLIGARCH, STRANGELY, IS
BEING SANCTIONED BY THE U.K.,
BUT NOT BY THE BY DEMONSTRATION.
THE BY DEMONSTRATION FOR ALL OF
ITS BELLICOSE TALK ABOUT RUSSIA,
HAS DECIDED NOT TO SANCTION
THE ONE OLIGARCH WHO IS
FRIENDS WITH THE PRESIDENT'S SO.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
UKRAINE.
THE WAR IN UKRAINE DOES NOT HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH UKRAINE, THE
LONG-TERM FORTITUDE OF THE
COUNTRY OR THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF ITS PEOPLE.
HAS TO DO WITH A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS.
THE BY DEMONSTRATION'S REQUEST
FOR UKRAINE AID, DIDN'T SEE THIS
COMING, INCLUDES A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR AFGHAN REFUGEES,
THEIR SPOUSES, AND CHILDREN.
"THE SECRETARY OF HOMELAND
SECURITY AND THE SECRETARY'S
DISTRACTION MAY ADJUST THE
STATUS OF AN AFGHAN NATIONAL TO
THAT OF AN INDIVIDUAL LAWFULLY
PERMITTED FOR PERMANENT
RESIDENCE."
OH.
SO IN AN PACKAGE MEANT TO DEFEND
THE BORDERS OF ANOTHER SOVEREIGN
NATION, WE CONTINUE TO DEGRADE
OUR OWN.
BUT YOU DIDN'T THINK DEFENDING
UKRAINIAN DEMOCRACY MEANT
ADMITTING TEN THOUSANDS OF MORE
FOREIGN NATIONALS INTO THIS
COUNTRY OVERNIGHT.
OF IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY OUR
LEADERS ARE DETERMINED TO
ESCALATE THIS CONFLICT, THERE'S
YOUR ANSWER.
IT MEANS MORE POWER FOR THEM.
IT MEANS REVENGE FOR THE 2016
ELECTION, AND IF THAT MEANS